bonjour madame c'est dans ce lieu local
au marché des clayes-sous-bois que la
candidate anne claire frémont sapeur
pompier de métier va à la rencontre des
habitants
est-ce que vous avez une autre oui vous
avez des questions le développement du
commerce de la ville et sa vie
économique sont des enjeux importants
pour la liste les clayes-sous-bois c'est
vous notamment pour cette ancienne vice
présidente de l'association des
commerçants de la ville
en tout premier lieu il faudrait engager
un manager de commerce local qui
travaillerait en concertation avec les
commerçants la ville et les élus
permettrait de redynamiser la ville
grâce à des animations grâce à une
diversité de commerces locaux un peu
plus présente
et puis travailler vraiment concertation
dans le cadre de la mise en place d'une
nouvelle association des commerçants
éventuellement je pense que les
animations fait revenir éventuellement à
une brasserie un pub ou un commerce de
bouche serait un véritable atout pour la
commune parmi les autres propositions du
programme un projet le tutti passeur
d'art s'adonne possibilité à une tranche
d'âge d'enfants pendant trois ans
d'avoir un instrument de musique
gratuitement et des cours de musique
gratuitement son temps scolaire et
périscolaire et qui permet de monter un
orchestre municipale en partenariat avec
les associations puisqu'en parallèle
nous souhaitons de cet orchestre
municipal en faire un orchestre
intergénérationnel et si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas on est tous les
dimanches et les jeux du marché il ya
des réunions publiques elle la prochaine
réunion publique est organisée à 10h30
samedi 7 mars à l'école henri proulx